Hello everybody. Welcome to a new episode of the
Center. I'm your host as always Ricardo Loops. And
today I'm joined by Doctor James mccann. He's Professor
Emeritus of History at Boston University. His research and
teaching interests include agricultural and ecological history of Africa,
Ethiopia, and the Horn of Africa field research methods
in African studies, the Agroecology of tropical disease and
the history of food slash cuisine in Africa and
the Atlantic world. And today we are going to
focus mostly on his book, Maize and Grace, a
History of Africa's Encounter with the new world crop.
So, Doctor mccann, welcome to the show. It's a
huge pleasure to everyone.
Thank you for your invitation.
So, uh let's start, I guess at the beginning.
So uh we're going to talk about maize here
today. Where did maize originate from?
Maize is a new world crop that was um
domesticated by peoples in Mesoamerica. And it's difficult, we
don't know the exact the first example of something
we would call maize in the common term. But
there are examples of, of um archaeological evidence of
forgive the bat cave where they found something that
looks a bit like maize that has is on
a, on the ear with a, with a cob.
Um And the evolution is the experimentation by local
farmers. We don't know men and women both were
involved probably. But we don't really know that in
Mesoamerica, but the characteristics that were evolved over time
was farmer selection of certain characteristics they wanted to
have available in their own diets and their own
food. And maize is remarkable and it's spread internationally.
That's why my interest in the arrival of maize
and its propagation in Africa. It it's about farmer
household, local knowledge only to some degree about elite
a applications. So it's the earliest history we don't
really know for sure. The spread me America into
North America and as far as New England. And
for example, this is an exa example of a
New England flint and eight rows and it's not
something commercially viable, but it represents the kind of
movement of, of, of Mays into new environments. This
other example here you see this looks like what
Columbus would have brought with him. He brought Mays
back from the Caribbean, a Caribbean red flint, which
is this one to Europe and he sent it
to his friends in different places in Germany and
Italy and Spain. And it began to be experimented
with and eventually was taken over by farmers themselves
who were the key innovators both in Africa and
in Europe. When May spread as this popular crop
that had certain characteristics that were overwhelmingly popular with
farmers as they sought to both be commercial but
also to feed their local populations.
And what are some of those characteristics? What are
the most distinct traits of mace
maize is one, it is wind pollinated in another.
It's not pollinated by insects or by um by
other means. And on the maize plant, you have
both male and female parts of the plant plant.
So it can self pollinate. But for the most
part, the wind moves the pollen between fields and
between plants. So you get automatically a mix, genetic
mixing that gives you a final result of texture
color and the characters characteristics of the plant itself.
So it has this characteristic that farmers have, have,
have the ability to control it by by hand
moving the column. Um SO that they have characteristics
that they favor whether it's color or texture or
for example, how long it stores? Uh SOME varieties
of maize do not store very long at all,
you have to consume them or they go bad,
other ones will last longer. So farmers are making
these choices over generations. What the end result is?
You find the difference between these two. I would
say it's all about the farmer choices. Another lead
scientist, the farmer choices at the early level and
the popularity of it as it spread around the
world was because it was controllable along with other
new world. Um ADDITIONS like capsicum pepper. We can't
recognize world cuisines without recognizing the contribution of pepper
capsicum. Uh In Indian, Indian Ethiopia, all varieties of
taste that we value coming from those new world
exchanges with new world. Yeah.
And uh what are some of the ways maize
differs from other uh common crops?
Well, as I said, the wind pollination factor is
something that farmers have to learn to control all
the way to Monsanto. Suing farmers for the pollen
being carried by the wind across fields in Iowa
um or or elsewhere where the control of the
pollen is the key issue about how do you
make it commercially viable. Um But the the difference
when something like wheat, wheat is wheat is self
pollinating, it doesn't, the pollen does not move more
than a few microns from different parts of the
plant. Rice is is self pollinating. Uh So maize
dis distinctive and it is wind pollinated, not insect
pollinated and that makes a huge difference. But farmers
understood this pretty quickly when any place where we
see where maize has become adapted as a ma
a major crop, you see that farmers are adjusting
their own knowledge systems to the characteristics of maize.
Maize is hermaphrodite. It represents both genders on the
same club, but it also is uh I guess
morally and and unquestionably about sharing sexual engagements,
right? And so, I mean, we're also going to
talk about how maize spread across the globe and
specifically uh in Africa. Uh BUT what are, are
there specific ecological conditions where maize produces high higher
yields, where it grows, it grows and is farmed
the best?
Well, of course, that's a key characteristic. And when
maize came from, you know, directly, for example, from,
from the Atlantic trade with Brazil and the trade,
the Atlantic trade of course has is a complex
interaction of sugar and human labor, forced labor, you
know, slaves um going across and carrying maize as
a potential crop brought into the African case into
West Africa, later into Southern Africa. But also up
the Nile and into the Indian Ocean world where
the word the the Kiswahili word for maize is
Muindi. It's from India. It doesn't come, didn't come
from India. But the the understanding, the popular understanding
of where this thing came from became the name.
If we look at the name for maize in
different cultures, different languages. We learned a lot about
people's perceptions of that crop. Um In, in Malawi,
for example, the word the word for, for maize,
it means um from our ancestors, even though it
came fairly late into place like Malawi, we replaced
sorghum. Sorghum is not as productive as maize and,
and farmers at each location, whether it's tropical, subtropical
um or somewhat um affected by the amount of
moisture available by rainfall by, by climate farmers adjusted
to that. So you see the varieties of maize
in all over the world ad adapted and again,
not so much like recent times by corporations who
are, who are attempting to make maize science. And
that's the sort of dominant the farmers made this
choice every year when they selected their seeds, they
would, they would choose some of the, some of
the Mazier for seed and some for consumption. And
the seed represented their sense of what they identified
is the characteristics they wanted. And that includes the
maize plant as forage, for animals. So for example,
in Italy, the the the the the fact that
the farm that the peasant farmers were able to
use the maize plant, not just the the the
ear, but the plant itself to feed their cattle
meant that they could keep the cattle in the
barns on their farm and not send them into
the mountains in the winter. And what they get
from that is distinctive kinds of products of the
animals were eating the maize such as Parmesan, such
as Gorgonzola, the cheeses, Italians, Italy is so well
known for is part of the product of maize
is at the core feeding of the animals. So
they can be kept in the barns and fed
over the course of the winter. And thus ST
storing the the milk in the form of cheese.
So it's not that uh maize uh only uh
I mean grows well or produces a good yield,
good yields in specific climates. I mean different kinds
of maize have been adapted to different sorts of
uh climates and environments. Yeah. With
the restrictions on maize, within the constraints that farmers
would respect would would um develop is maize is
is vulnerable to drought moisture sensitive. So if you,
if you have a drought prone area, either seasonally
or within a year, you have to realize that
maize is vulnerable to, to moisture, to moisture uh
availability. The other way, maize tends does not store
as long as other crops, millets store for a
very long time. Ethiopian crop tiff will, will store
for years. Maze, you get four months, maybe maximum
six months but unlikely. So you've got to eat
it, move it, preserve it somehow. So it has
those constraints on maze. And so that's why you
don't see maze as a domino c everywhere.
OK. Uh And when it comes, uh we've, you've
already mentioned some of that but when it comes
how and why it spread across the globe apart
from the trades you've already mentioned, were there any
specific, for example, political or economic reasons for it
to become so widespread?
Uh uh Well, yes, one, it's, here's an example
and this is not from the Africa work I
did, but the work I've done in Italy where
the key crop for the veto. Venice was an
empire, an empire of trade. But they, the, the,
the Venetian patricians, the rich folks in Venice itself
told the farmers on the terra firma of who
they controlled that. You will pay your taxes and
wheat. And the farmer said wheat doesn't work well
here in northern northern Italy, wheat works in southern
Italy and elsewhere. So we want to start paying
our taxes in maize. And at first, the patricians
in Venice said, no, we want wheat and we
control you. So the battle eventually was won by
the peasants in the terra firma. And because of
the, the, the the plague and other kinds of
situations, they won the day and were allowed to
pay their taxes in maize. And of course, maize
then becomes the basis for the diet in northern
Italy of polenta rather than pasta is an importation
from Southern Italy. And the same thing happens where
maize is introduced in uh in Africa where fa
farmers find it help help important to adapt maize
as their fundamental crop. But one of the liabilities
of maize is it has insufficient amino acids. So
you have the pro from palabra is disease that
you find especially in agricultural societies in Southern the
American South, in Italy and any and in southern
Africa, any place you have a dominance of maize
in the diet that came as part of, of
maize being a really popular crop for farmers to
grow is Pella is a skin disease and you
find it places where the diet becomes too dependent
on maize. But you don't find that in Mid
America because in Mesoamerica, they process maize using lies
and change the chemistry so that you get a
complete uh amino acid and complete protein by having
a maize based diet. It has to do with
processing. How do you process the maze? But they
didn't do that in um in other places, Italy,
Africa, the southern us where Pella becomes a serious
problem until it's understood that you have to complete
the proteins by, by research in the early 20th
century.
And when exactly did maize get to Africa?
Well, we don't, of course, completely know, but we
can look at um places early on, we begin
to get adaptation. For example, a na uh the
names given to maize you find in places in
Nigeria or West Africa that the the words for
maize tell us something. The the um the Akan
in Ghana, uh the word for, for, for maize
means something from the foreigners in Ethiopia. Then one
of the words for a maze was Yar Maila.
In other words, the sor go from across the
ocean, it looks maize looks like. So, so sorghum
or Sorghum looks like maize when it's growing early
on. But that the factor of people recognizing saying
it's the so them from across the sea. And
now when you go to to the place of
within Ethiopia, I work, it's just called Mahila, which
just means Sorghum, it's not Sorghum. But people understand
that the word tells you people's perceptions of when
this arrived. Uh So exact dates by the time
the Portuguese arrive in Ethiopia, they're finding some maize
there and they tell us what they're growing. And
you can see the maize has already arrived. But
we don't have a clear historical record because that's
something takes place in the basic level of human
subsistence and doesn't make it into the historical sources
quite as clearly as it does later on.
And how does maize tie to Africa's Green Revolution?
Well, the Green Revolution originally was done with rice
for South Asia. So, so for India, South Asia
and so that revolution was about doing short, short
that you have to have, you have to have
water and you have to have fertilizer and you
get a huge growth in food production in South
Asia for Africa. The the the attempt has been
to say yes, maize is going to be for
Africa like rice was for South Asia and that's
done by has been done by corporations by USA
ID International Organizations. Um The key center for research
on maize is in Mexico City when I visited
there. Uh I was taken to uh there was
Ethiopian there who I got, I work in Ethiopia.
So we became friends. He took me to a
rural site outside of Mexico City. Uh AND they
were growing their maize seed for which was going
to be introduced to Ethiopia. Uh So the international
nature of the research going on now the Green
Revolution, the idea was maize can be the center
point of that for Africa, but with the problems
that maze has about stability and about incomplete proteins.
And so what he this Ethiopian scientist was doing,
I'm developing a new variety with complete um proteins.
So it would have to be identified having a
market value, you pay more for those seeds to
have complete proteins. And this this uh type of
maize though was also introduced elsewhere in Africa is
part of what people hoped would be a green
rev kind of green revolution. And it has done
that the improvement in the the yield of the
maize, you improve maize is substantial to um 68
tons per hectare compared to two tons per hectare
in local varieties. So that is Africa was has
been seen as the key to that in many
ways. It is although for example, Ethiopian restaurants are
very popular in around the world but in in
the US and in in Europe and you will
not find maize even though it's the number one
crop in Ethiopia, you will not find maize on
the diet of Ethiopia, the menu of Ethiopian restaurants
because it's not traditionally their ideal food, the food
of poverty. Um YOU can buy ears of maize
on the street, roasted maize on the street, very
inexpensive. But as a as a fund fundamental part
of diet problematic.
And why is it that uh when it comes
to Africa, people decided on maize? I mean, why
wasn't it some other crop.
Well, they have, you can, you can look at
each individual situation. The place I work in Ethiopia,
they had a full maize came very late. It
was there as a garden crop, early yielding. It's
the first crop of the year. You have it
in your, your household garden. Um, YOU get the
first milky stage, you can eat milky stage maize
or wait, wait till it dries and then process
it. But it's the first crop you're going to
get. Um But there, there they had other crops,
they had death in wheat and barley. And it
was a very, very diversified cropping system. The farmers
understood well in other places, places in Southern Africa,
for example, it arrived, it replaced Sorghum because it
was much more productive. And the African farmers all
over Southern Africa said this thing will give us
a yield quickly and it is a food that
we can adapt into our diet. So sorghum has
almost disappeared. And maize is the crop that has
many different varieties in all the countries of Southern
Africa. All different names. Basically, it's what Americans would
call, call grits or Italians would call polenta. Uh
So maze in its various forms, ref reflects the
the choice of farmers to say this thing gives
an early yield. But the new varieties, the green
revolution varieties yield much later and you don't eat
them at the m milky stage. At the green
stage. You have, you have to wait and dry
them and then process them. So it feeds into
the industrialization of of mills that began to change
the way that the market affected. What kind of
maize farmers were growing. And the government would say,
ok, you may, may grow only this kind of
maize because we cannot sell colored maize. B maize
drops out of the market because the international market
say we want white maize. And if yellow maize
is grown, yellow maize is useful for poultry who
likes white yolks and their eggs, the yellow comes
from the beta carotene in the yellow maize. Hm
So you have these adaptations where the Millers are
saying we want this kind of maize because that's
the one we can sell into international markets. And
so you have it for Africa. Virtually all of
the African maize is white in the US, maize
is for livestock and you want your, your the
fat of your livestock to be kind of a
little bit yellow. So the the yellow maize is
dominant in North America and in Europe too, white
maize is still there. You can buy polenta, either
white or red, depending on your taste. What you're
eating the polenta with, with, with fish or with
uh with, with the tomato sauce, et cetera. So
these are consumer preferences that reflect the larger market
preferences of the kind of maize that farmers are
going to be growing to produce commercially for the
market.
So uh politics and economics also certainly play a
big role in the adoption and spread of maize
across Africa.
Right? Yes. So if you look at a place
like Zimbabwe, which did fantastic research on maize development,
the law system eventually through the 20th century said,
OK, you may not grow maize which is not
white. Uh BECAUSE white is the international market and
we're producing some of the best hybrid maize developed
through research came out not out of the North
America, out of Rhodesia, Southern Rhodesia, which became Zimbabwe.
Because the the, the, the maize, the scientists there,
the white, the white Rhodesian scientists developed a incredibly
productive uh variety. But for that variety of, of
really um productive maze in terms of, of the
of the economic perspective that you had to have
just the right soils, just the right moisture, just
the right seasonal conditions. And of course, the white
population in Southern Rhodesia controlled those things. And the
the black farmers were not given access to this
new variety. These new varieties incredibly productive is from
a scientific point of view, economic point of view.
But you also founded. This is a story I
got when I was doing work, work in Zimbabwe,
one of those scientists showed me a chart he
made, he said, chart showed, wait a second. Why
is suddenly this this production going up? But we're
not, we're not charting. He said in his own
handwriting, he wrote in this little chart from the
19 sixties. He showed me this chart when I
interviewed him, he wrote African farmers. In other words,
African farmers had found the, the, the new crop,
the new variety and were using it and adapting
it in their own terms. Even though the government
was trying to suppress their, their role in production
of, of, of maize. Very, very, very political economic,
in a fascinating way, which is what led me
into and what led me into you didn't ask
this question, but I'll answer it anyway. How did
I begin to understand and, and want to explore
more of the role of maize because I grew
up with maize fields all around me as a
kid. I grew up in Illinois and Illinois is
a big maize producing area. But when I was
interviewing farmers in Ethiopia after the famine, uh there
was a socialist government in place that was trying
to control farmer activities and farmers were growing their
different varieties of crops. And then suddenly when I
said, OK, what did you go last year, the
year before that? It's a year before that. They
were saying, well, this is the maize, maize, maize,
maize. Really? I said maize is drought is drought
um affected. Um IT, it it is not the
best nutrition in the world, it doesn't fit your
normal diet. Why are you doing this? And so
I began to understand it's because the government is
saying we don't care what you grow as long
as you pay in these other crops. And they
said that maize was safe because the government wouldn't
take it from him. It was a political decision
that, that affected what farmers did,
right? Uh And uh I mean, uh going along
the uh that line of what uh I would
also like to ask you a little bit about
the particular case of South Africa, which you have
done some work on. Uh YOU mentioned science there
for example. And I asked you about politics, but
in the particular case of South Africa, uh in
what ways did politics, science and race intermingle there?
Well, for Southern Africa, we you know the politics,
we know of the the arrival of Europeans in
the 17th century and then spread from the cape
into colonial settings that were originally the the arrival
of uh Dutch later on the the the British
Empire incorporated that but the basic population still was
agricultural. Um And they of course had needs for
the mines. So the Southern African economies were about
gold first, sorry, diamonds first, then gold and that
became the diamond. So what do you need? You
need labor? Mhm And when the labor is the
black population which needs to be fed and the
the mine owners were having to determine what do
we feed our mine workers to keep them healthy
enough to work and maize became the key crop
for them. Uh And the the word Milly. Milly
pop is a South African word for polenta or
for the basic maize, which comes from the Portuguese
Mili. So merely was not maize, but word came
to include maize from the original Portuguese. And so
you have this phenomenon of the mind economy, creating
a sense of what is what is good food.
Um And eventually the population came to define their
full bellies is the feeling you get when you've
eaten a big batch of maize. And when that
becomes a kind of a cultural norm of what
feeling full is um maize becomes that key ingredient.
So the the miners also went back to their
family farms when they worked, headed out of the
mines and they began to grow maize as down
the crop. And that was women doing the work
back home where men were the miners earning wages.
And therefore the the core diet became maze because
it was low labor, lower labor. Somebody I did
mention maze takes less labor, you can broadcast it.
Um You don't have to do it by role,
et cetera. Uh So its characteristics meant it could
be adapted on small farms in which women's labor
was the key issue. So Southern Africa, it was
about mining, the economy and eventually became the accepted
um diet was maize was the core of any
meal. Yes, there was sorghum a little bit here
and there. You can still buy some Sorghum in
South African. Uh GRO groceries. But for the most
part, the basic diet is maize, white maze. Mhm.
Right. And do we know if uh maize has
had uh any impact on the biodiversity of Africa?
Well, in some ways, it's a negative effect because
the farmer incentives with political context in many cases
is maize is the crop that's really yielding. It
gives a very good yield for small farmers and
you go to, you know, 6 to 8 tons
per hectare of the new varieties. So farmers are
seeking both the commercial value of that to to
send to the the cities but also it is
very, very attractive is the local diet. Um So
the biodiversity pushing maize as as USA ID does
with the Agra, the the this big development program
based upon maize is the primary crop. Uh So
you have corporations Mon Monsanto and of course May's
production, Monsanto is now owned by by year. So
the big maize producers are all owned by drug
companies by chemical companies. Dupont owned all of those,
those early developers of of maize in North America
in Europe are all owned by now. Chemical drug
companies, Dupont Bayer um go down the line. So
it it becomes a corporate crop and farmers are
are dealing with markets and their own food supply
depending on where you are in Africa. Maize is
not the dominant crop in every part of Africa.
It is in, it is in southern Africa. It
is in Kenya, Tanzania. Ugali is essentially grits polenta.
But for, for East Africa and that's I had
a friend, a Ugandan friend who came to Ethiopia
and she was dying to have ugali in her
diet because she's from Uganda and for her food,
met maize. At that point, Ethiopian restaurant, Ethiopian national
diet did not really include maize for the middle
and upper class. So, Mays has his fun role,
role. It's not a friend of biodiversity. Mhm
And uh a related question, do we know what
impact uh the introduction of maize had on African
people's nutrition and health.
Well, I mentioned pra too much dependent on maize
but maize has its place because it yields early
depending on the variety you're growing. You can be
can be the first thing that comes as the
first crop you have. We have often Af African
cultures have celebrations of the first crop. The the
new year begins. The first thing you can get
is maize because you can eat it the milky
stage as we eat with with uh we haven't
mentioned there are five varieties of maize, one of
which is sweet corn, uh which is the one
you eat at the milky stage. It's wonderful, delicious.
Um Something in the fall when the first maze
comes in, you wanna have um sweet corn. There's
also popcorn, also dent corn, also flint corn. These
are both flint corns which has the characters are
scoring longer uh which is a good thing, but
they may take longer to mature and you're not,
you're not consuming them at the early stage. So
the the the role of maize in the diet
differs on which kind of cuisines you're talking about
which parts of Africa, Africa, of course, is a
wonderfully diverse place, linguistically, culturally, in terms of diet
and maize plays an important part in a number
of different African diets. Mhm.
So for the second part of the interview, let's
say, I would like to ask you a few
more general questions not specifically related to maize itself.
So uh particularly when I asked you about Southern
Africa and also earlier in the interview, you mentioned
a little bit of it, uh we talked about
colonialism. So uh what would you say was the
role played by colonialism when it comes to spreading
crops across the globe? And uh how was the
adoption of different crops influenced by it?
Well, it depends on the situation. We have an
example of Ethiopia where there was not formal colonialism.
The Italian period was only a few years. So
the adaptation was done essentially by farmers themselves, taking
advantage of what is available to them in terms
of their own strategies of cropping across a year
and feeding their community with a little bit of
commercials, selling of, of grains. But also the household
level. When you go to a place like Southern
Africa or or so Southern Africa, you have a
large arrival of the European population who are originally
Dutch and then English and then some Portuguese and
different, different groups arrive there. Europeans who control things
who are interested in feeding their labor and feeding
themselves. So you have in South Africa. So a
wonderful um tradition now of wine because some of
the early migrants out of Europe were Huguenots. The
huguenots were escaping France because they were oppressed by
the Cat Catholic majority there. And they began importing
uh vineyards and that became now today, some of
the best places to go and on wine tours
in the world. In my experience, South Africa is
fantastic. Um And that links to the minefields needed
labor. The certain minefield, the vineyards needed labor and
those laborers were eating increasingly maize getting back to
maze but it was and some places there was
not a European population in East Africa, Kenya a
little bit Tanzania. You had European populations that were
affecting what farmers were doing because they're expected that
farmers would grow crops consumed by Europeans. Uh West
Africa, the conditions of malaria, something else I work
on malaria meant that Europeans and large populations did
not populate West Africa, they would tend to populate
as in, in um in India hill stations that
were fear from malaria. So Europeans would con control
those spaces and so the population was allowed to
keep um local varieties of foodstuffs. So for example,
in West Africa, you had the possibility of, of
uh maize could be there as a first crop
if you're clearing your forest. But the, the crops
you really want to have in there are yam
cassava, another manio, another new world crop. Uh If
you, you know bubble tea. Uh YES, the bubbles
are maniac. A casa. We were OK. Uh So
you have these mixes sometimes called the Colombian exchange
of crops coming from the old new world to
the old world. I call it the I call
it not the exchange, but the circulation because the
food crops along with peoples are circulating and bringing
their preferred foods with them. So in West Africa,
you have forest crops, yams, they're, they're grown in
the, in the, in the, in the forest floor.
Uh Maize is there for the first crop but
then people want to get into yams and, and
cassava and other kinds of crops taken from the
forest, the biodiversity of the forest. So all that's
changing, of course as cities grow. But the colonial
effect is greatest in some places where there could
be new neo Europe such as southern Africa, Kenya.
But where there's factions of disease, the African population
had resistance to uh the Europeans would tend to
avoid those areas, control them for pro production of
food and for mining, et cetera. But uh maize
there was, it's, it's it's interest came from farmers
themselves. But also because Europeans were happy to have
those workers under, under colonial rule fed and the
maze then became a key part of that process
of nutrition. Mhm.
So uh in historical scholarship, one approach that people
have is to look at the causal relationship between
climate and history. Uh What do you think of
it?
Climate is fundamental to history, climate about seasonality. What
is the annual cycle of, of availability of moisture?
Uh Disease is also sea seasonal affected by climate
by issues of climate. It's the thing I'm working
on now is sort of the more fundamental issue
about water, water, its presence, its absence, its movement,
it's movement through the seasons. And this is deeply
within the issue of climate change, climate change, velvet
of water. But of course, just look at today's
stuff in, in Ukraine. But what do you do
when you want to defeat your enemy? This is
what the Germans did in Italy in World War
Two. They said we're gonna stop the allied invasion
in Italy by flooding the farmers' fields because then
that will encourage malaria which will affect the invading
army. In this case, the British American uh invasion
of Italy. And that was a specific military plan,
what's going on now, even though we're not quite
identifying the source of it. This is what the
Russians are doing. They said we're going to blow
up this dam and we're gonna flood this entire
area to impede the movement of, of, of military
activity and this gets back to the seasons in
which empires within Africa, within Ethiopia. For example, the
the the armies moved only during the dry season.
If you move during the wet season, then the
areas with malarial. Uh SO the seasonality of wind
moisture is available is a big deal militarily in
terms of the production of food. In terms of,
you know, if you, if you look at people
who are traveling, describing events in Africa or the
conditions in Africa, Europeans writing down what they're, what
they're encountering, they only traveled in the dry season.
They're only giving a partial view of what they're
seeing because they wouldn't go during the wet season
because it's one, it's muddy two, it's malarial and
the local merchants and, and uh moving around are
only doing their movement during that seasonality. The seasons
change, different parts of Africa, but it's that seasonal
change and the, the issue of climate change, which
is now having major effects, right?
Uh So I would like to ask you one
last question slash topic. So, uh of course, when
it comes to history, um I would like to
ask you, what do you think of approaches by
people like Jared Diamond when it comes to explaining
why certain societies became more successful than others and
what we could call or at least some people
call uh geographical determinism.
Well, that's always been a factor of how much
is, are the conditions deterministic and Jared Diamond lays
out an argument. That's interesting. To challenge and it's
good that it's there. And it's, it's, it's an
attempt at universal explanation of human movement, human political
economic domination based around on environmental issues to some
degree. That's true. Um And I think that that
any consideration of politics or of economic change or
of interaction between different kinds of political systems um
has its foundations, environmental issue in environmental issues. The
fact that Europeans coming to Africa or even to
North America or to, to the new world. It's
about the movement of knowledge. Part of that Colombian
circulation I mentioned was the arrival in Latin America
of people who knew how to deal with couple
of climates. The people, the the the selection of
who is that most valued as labor out of
the slave trade, going to the to the Carolinas
in the US because the ones who are most
valued came from Santa Gambia. They knew how to
grow rice and the the plantation owners. And so
in, in um in the Carolinas were stayed in
their, their uplands and in areas that were not
so much so affected by malaria or other diseases
and their, their African slaves were allowed to move
into swampy areas because they knew how to grow.
Um LOVE rima rice. They were adapting the environment,
they knew, they knew how to deal with health,
knew how to deal with production. And so the
knowledge that moved into the new world also was
a key part of this whole exchange and politics
got into who controlled who but also adaptation to
environmental issues. If you want to understand the geography
of Ethiopia is a, is a place that's a
place I work. Most, you know, look at climate
seasonality and you see that people would move in
and out of areas that were affected by malaria
or where they could grow one crop or another
crop and then harvest it and get back to
a safer area. Big factor and you a diamond
is helpful to have that, that um that perspective
that is environmental determinism, but they will have nuance
by local areas. And that's the beautiful part of
doing the, doing the work and working with different
people in different places.
Mhm. So, yeah. Uh I mean, I've also asked
you about that because of course, a big part
of Jared Diamond's argument is based on uh crops
also, of course domesticated animals in certain specific latitudes
in the world. Uh And uh since of course,
our interview has been focused so much on maize
and we touched on some other crops as well.
Uh I was wondering, I mean, to what extent
you would think um the factors that Jared Diamond
points to uh I, I mean, what uh how
much of a role do you think they would
play in human history?
Well, I would add to Jared Diamond as, as
a um kind of marker of environmental determinism with
a reasonable coherent and somewhat persuasive argument. But look
at Alfred Crosby who coined the term the Columbian
exchange that I modified to publicly of the interaction.
Um It is is that uh Alfred Crosby talks
about the the biological imperialism because the the arrival
in the new world of cattle and pigs, right?
And chickens and part of this global circulation transforms
the the physical environment. When you release hogs into
the environment, they are extremely good at going feral
and they, they, they change the physical world they
live in and humans are both either hunting them
or trying to domesticate them or the the animals
and the plants, of course, maize being a big
one of globalization, but this is also true of
other, other crops and other kinds of animals. Um
YOU know, goats, sheep, cattle, horses, all of these
things that transform the worlds they they move to
and the adaptation of local populations quickly to the
horse. For example, you know, native Americans in North
America adaptations of the horse, suddenly they become mobile,
suddenly they, they're able to hunt in different ways.
Suddenly they're able to, to to expand their own
local local control over different com competing groups in
new, in new ways. So the the Alfred Crosby
approach to this, which has been adapted by people,
scholars from, from all over the world are incorporating
these ideas and and playing them out in local
areas that makes sense for them. But Jared Diamond
more popular is, is something to read. Uh It's
kind of New York Times best seller list. But
the Alfred Crosby stuff is also uh to me
uh very good. And the colleagues I work with
who are specialists when I, when I go someplace,
it's not that I know things others don't know.
But I absorb as his historian, I'm absorbing the
knowledge and interacting with my colleagues, whether it's in
Ghana, we were talking about the introduction of maize
or in Ethiopia where we're driving through the countryside
and I'm saying, what's going on there? We're walking
through the countryside. And I'm always asking questions because
they have the knowledge that I've been trying to
interpret for a larger uh audience as an academic,
as a historian. So these things are very, very
global, it helps to have people kind of tweaking
the narrative by publishing books like Jared Diamond. But
it's not that we say gee he's got it.
Right. Um He's after all, you know, his original
background, he's a gastroenterologist. Mhm. Right. And we trust
doctors to a degree. Yes.
Yeah. Right. So uh Doctor mccann, uh I'm leaving
a link to your book Maze And Grace, a
History of Africa's encounter with the new World Cup
crop in the description box of the interview. Uh
Would you like to mention any places on the
internet where people can find your work?
Well, I think the internet being what it is,
you can, you can do that. Um What I'm
getting now, I just was at Oxford University Press
asked me to write a chapter on malaria in
Africa. And malaria in Africa came from my own
work with, again, with colleagues um who work on
malaria in Africa and elsewhere. But um people I
got malaria when I was doing field work in
Africa uh in, in Ethiopia, you know, an area
where the maize stuff was going on. And I
didn't ask go malaria. But suddenly I had 100
and five degree fever and had to go back
out of my my rural area five hours by
mule to get to the nearest road to the
nearest light bulb. Oh my God. And so malaria
became an interest and the maze. Malaria connection is
one chapter of of um maize and grace. And
so male malaria is where I I appear on
the internet. I'm constantly getting notes saying you've been
cited by these 100 times. I said really I'm
not doing and it's, it's mainly now about the
medical malaria stuff that links to the maze. All
these things are linked. Um And now back to
the North Fundament of water in which I'm doing
a plenary panel for a international meeting in Finland
next year. And that is to draw people together
around what is the meaning of water? Meanings of
water as something physical is something psychological is something
cultural and water takes us to all kinds of
ways that people signify their sainthood if they're in
a, in a, uh religious religious setting. Um, AND
for example, in the 88, the 18 fifties, this
short story, the British traveler in Ethiopia came down
with fever and it's called eu, he understood this
as I have a fever. What do I do?
He's riding around the countryside with people and they
said, what you need to do is stand in
this tree and we're gonna dump water on your
head and this will deal with your fever. He
said, well, first of all, it knocked him off,
his horse, knocked him senseless and he felt slightly
better at the end of this ordeal. At the
same time, there's someone in Malvern England who's going
through a water therapy treatment, somewhat, somewhat similar and
that person was Charles Darwin. So water is this,
this, this universal, of course, it's universal, but the
nuances and local cultures and local material versus belief
systems is the thing that I'm working on now.
And you find examples of that all over the
world where suddenly cli that links to climate change.
Very interesting. So, Doctor mccann, uh thank you so
much for taking the time to come on the
show. It's been a real pleasure to talk to
you
too. Say no or the equivalent of the Italian.
Yeah. In this case, uh it would be bo
part here. It's still the afternoons. OK?
Time change, time change. So thank you very much
Ricardo. Very interesting. You're, you're uh you're a good,
you're a good interviewer.
Thank you. Hi guys. Thank you for watching this
interview. Until the end. If you liked it, please
do not forget to like it, share, comment and
subscribe. And if you like more generally what I'm
doing, please consider support the show on Patreon or
paypal. You have all of the links in the
description of this interview. This show is brought to
you by En Lights learning and development. Done differently.
Check their website at alights dot com. I would
also like to give a huge thank you to
my main patrons and paypal supporters per Larson, Jerry
Mueller and Frederick Sunda Bernards O of Election and
Viser Adam Castle Matthew Whit Whitting Bear, no wolf,
Tim Hollis, Eric Alania John Connors, Philip Forrest, Connelly,
Robert Winde, Nai Zoup, Mark Nevs Colin Holbrook, Simon
Columbus Phil, Governor Michael Stormer Samuel Andreev for the
Alexander Dan Bauer, Fergal Ken Hall, her og Michel
Jonathan lebron Jars and the Samuel K, Eric Heins,
Mark Smith, Jan We Amal S Franz David Sloan
Wilson Yasa Des Roma Roach Diego, Jannik Punter, Da
Man Charlotte Bli Nicole Barbar Wam and Pao Assy
Naw Guy Madison, Gary GH, some of the Adrian
Yin Nick Golden Paul talent in Ju Bar was
Julian Price Edward Hall, Eden Bronner, Douglas Fry Franca
Bertolotti, Gabriel Pan Cortez Lelis Scott Zachary Fish, Tim
Duffy, Sonny Smith, John Wiesman, Martin Aland, Daniel Friedman,
William Buck. Paul George Arnold Luke Lo A Georges
the offense, Chris Williamson, Peter Oren David Williams the
Costa Anton Erickson Charles Murray, Alex Shaw and Murray
Martinez Chevalier, Bangalore atheists Larry Daley Junior, Holt Eric
B. Starry Michael Bailey then Sperber Robert Grassy Rough
the RP MD. Ior Jeff mcmahon, Jake Zul Barnabas
Radix, Mark Campbell, Richard Bowen Thomas the Dubner, Luke
Ni and Greece story, Manuel Oliveira, Kimberly Johnson and
Benjamin Gilbert. A special thanks to my producers, these
our web gem Frank Luca Stan. Tom Weam Bernard
ni Ortiz Dixon Benedict Mueller Vege, Gli Thomas Trumble,
Catherine and Patrick Tobin John Carlo Montenegro, Robert Lewis
and Al Nick Ortiz. And to my executive producers,
Matthew Lavender, Serge Adrian and Bogdan Kut. Thank you
for all.